foreign
heavy fighting spreads through cartoon
as tensions between the Sudanese Army
and a powerful paramilitary force spill
over into the streets
the Army says it's defending itself from
attacks by the rapid support forces
across the capital it's now designating
the force as a rebel group
The rsf is trying to assault many
critical positions our forces are
deployed and discharging their duties
defending those positions fighting has
been underway since this morning until
this moment this is a battle for our
national dignity
but the rapid support forces say their
bases were attacked by the army
metal will pave the way to a peaceful
solution all those criminals will stand
trials I cannot give a time limit to the
fighting however we are adamant to end
it with the least of losses
all flights have been canceled at
Khartoum International Airport where
armed men are on the tarmac and Rapid
support forces have taken control of
State television service Sudan TV
this was the moment the station's
broadcast was cut
tensions between the Army and the rapid
support forces emerged months after a
military Takeover in 2021 and they
heightened when talks to integrate the
rsf into the army stalled
I really feel very sad and very angry
actually I'm enraged and I see I I I say
to both of them share my new both of you
you have been entrusted for this great
Revolution and uh you already committed
an nonsensical coup speaking in Vietnam
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
said Washington would continue to
support Sudan's transition to a
civilian-led government
it's a fragile situation
there are
other actors that may be
pushing against that that progress but
this is a real opportunity to finally
carry forward the civilian-led
transition and one that we and in other
countries
are trying to uh to bolster people
across Sudan are bracing themselves for
more fighting a new crisis and an
uncertain future Victoria Gayton B Al
Jazeera